AOC jumps on every rakin site Google
uncovers some inconvenient data about
the wage gap and British women panic
about global warming i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
I have to admit there are some days when
I have to rejigger the entire show
schedule because of breaking news in the
morning and this was one of those days I
didn't really want to talk about AOC but
now AOC has decided that she is just
going to let all of the silly flow free
just all of these silly and the malice
and the Animus flow free we'll talk
about it in just one second first let's
talk about the national debt in 2008 the
national debt was ten trillion dollars
today the debt is twenty two trillion
dollars and it is rising like a hockey
stick if you don't think that we're
sitting on a bit of a house of cards
here you're living with your head in the
sand but since you're listening to my
podcast that means you are clearly
smarter than the average American so
what is your plan can you afford another
hit to your retirement like the last
downturn when the S&P dropped 50% hedge
against inflation and hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases Birch gold group and right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can even move that IRA or eligible 401k
into an IRA backed by physical gold and
silver perfect for people who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from any future geopolitical
uncertainty look back historically when
the bottom falls out of everything else
gold it tends to safeguard savings Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact Birch gold group and get
a free information kit on physical
precious metal CF diversifying into gold
and silver at least a little make some
sense for you this comprehensive 16 page
kit shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings go check them out
right now by texting been to 47 47 47
that's to get your no cost no obligation
kit text Ben - 47 47 47 again text Ben
two four seven four seven four seven
alrighty so as I was saying the fact is
that every evening I put together the
schedule for this show the sort of
preliminary schedule then it very often
changes in the morning rarely does it
get completely overhauled this morning
was one of those mornings because AO she
decides that she is going to be
aggressively awful about everything in
the world at the same time now listen I
understand that we now live in a
political a political time when
aggressive ignorance is actually a
benefit in politics aggressive ignorance
because here's the thing the more you
know about various issues the more
nuanced your thinking tends to be or
that very
the more you tend to understand the ins
and outs of the opposing asides thinking
when you don't know things you tend to
speak in easy bumper stickers you tend
to say things that are bumper sticker
slogans and then people who don't know
much cheer you on and the nice thing
about easy bumper sticker slogans is
that when they are revealed to be
aggressively ignorance then you can
always backfill the ignorance you can
always create a nuanced backstory to try
and backfill the fact that you didn't
know what you were talking about in the
first place when you add on to this the
benefit of being an intersectional
leftist the soft bigotry of low
expectations that attends being a
minority or a woman or being a ranking
high on the intersectional scale people
are willing to let you off the hook
people are willing to attribute
aggressive ignorant to different
viewpoints that makes it pretty easy to
be a popular politician like in AOC
she's getting the benefit of the doubt
every which way and she simply does not
deserve it because she continues to make
mistakes and not just make mistakes say
things that are aggressively bad
aggressively morally bad so let's start
today with her take on the Afghanistan
war so she has decided that she is going
to defend obviously Ilhan Omar so you'll
recall that Ilhan Omar is an anti-semite
that she has repeatedly said
anti-semitic things over and over and
over again she apologized no less than
three times in the last six weeks for
anti-semitic remarks because she is in
fact saying things that reflect her
underlying worldview which is that the
Jews are a nefarious force in the world
and particularly in the United States
politics with regard to support for
Israel well AOC who is one of the fresh
faces incredibly fresh as well as face
of the new Democratic Congress along
with fellow Hanauma remember they both
appear on the cover of this month's
Rolling Stone with with Nancy Pelosi she
has decided to come out and defend
Ilhan Omar against her fellow Democrats
by the way so for example representative
Juan Vargas he said it is disturbing
that representative Omar continues to
perpetuate hurtful anti-semitic
stereotypes that misrepresent our Jewish
community and the response from AOC was
I'm curious if representative Vargas
will further explain his stance here
that it's unacceptable to even question
US foreign policy now that right off the
bat is a lie he is not saying the
question America's foreign policy what
he says is that questioning support for
the us-israel relationship on the basis
of conspiracy theories about Jews is
unacceptable that's what he is talking
about but aoc is going to deliberately
mischaracterize Vargas's statements so
she can defend el Han Omar now let's be
real about this hill hen Omar is an
anti-semite rashida to leave the
congresswoman from Michigan is an
anti-semite and AOC is perfectly
comfortable with anti-semitism I don't
mean little comfortable I mean obviously
and perfectly comfortable with it no
less than two weeks ago she tweeted out
her joy at speaking with open
anti-semite Jeremy Corbyn who's the head
of the British Labour Party so she is
fine with anti-semitism she hangs out
with anti-semites on a regular basis and
defends them on a regular basis
meanwhile you see folks on the political
left particularly Jewish folks on the
particular on the on the political left
- some of whom it happened to be
pro-israel wringing their hands and
clutching their pearls and oh isn't it
sad isn't it terrible that AOC just
doesn't know things this is where
aggressive ignorance really helps you
because again this isn't a matter of
aggressive ignorance she knows what
she's saying she just doesn't care very
much
anyway ALC continues she says plenty of
Democratic members have asserted that
discussion and debate on this issue is
fair and merited is this stance a
departure from that no it isn't you're
just deliberately mischaracterizing
Vargas's statements so that you can
pretend this is about free speech when
it really is about embracing
anti-semitism and then she continues and
here's where she fears from the
defensive anti-semites into ridiculously
ignorant territory for which she will be
excused by the media she says I remember
a time when it was unacceptable to
question the Iraq war all of Congress
was wrong including both GOP and dem
party and led my generation into a
disastrous and wrong war that virtually
all would come to regret except for the
one member who stood up barbara Lee a
barbara Lee was basically a communist
who actually stood against the
authorization for use of military force
in Afghanistan not Iraq when corrected
on her aggressive ignorance aoc then
said or now even with the disastrous
trace like Elliott Abrams at the helm a
man guilty of crimes related to
iran-contra including misleading
Congress it still seems like critiquing
us interventionism is taboo history
shows that making some questions
unacceptable is a mistake which is a
hilarious take from AOC who wants to
make all questions about her green New
Deal unacceptable
make she's the boss
she declared it she is the boss of the
green new deal unless somebody else
presents a plan that she gets on board
with which she won't
so she's the boss and if you question
her you're a climate denier but then it
gets even better
so she says all of this and then she
corrects herself about barbara Lee she's
the Afghanistan war she means the
Afghanistan war was bad she says
honestly we shouldn't have been in
either and we should end the AUMF now
while we're at it okay that's ridiculous
that is ridiculous we shouldn't have
been in the Afghanistan war and we
should end the AUMF now while we're at
it and then she's questioned about that
and people are going up are you saying
that after 9/11 we should not have gone
into Afghanistan is that your actual
contention aoc and she's like yeah maybe
sure why not
I mean it's really it's it's pretty
astonishing so she tweets out following
some blowback about this than what she
really means Jake Tapper asks her a
question about it Jake Tapper asks her
so what exactly do you mean by this
and she immediately responds by saying
well perhaps perhaps what we should have
done she says are I think our decision
to enter unlimited engagements in
Afghanistan
particularly through the AMF AUMF the
authorization for use of military force
and Congress's abdication of power and
decision-making what the passage of the
AUMF was a mistake and she says other
options targeting the network itself
limited engagement and non intervention
so she literally was saying non
intervention in the aftermath of 9/11
was another option and then she says
limited engagement or targeting the
network itself this is aggressively
fatuous aggressively fatuous because
again you have to be ignorance of
history to say this you could not target
al Qaeda in Afghanistan without entering
Afghanistan in the first place she says
target terrorist networks where does she
think al-qaeda was located I'm old
enough to remember 9/11 so is she by the
way and I'm old enough to remember when
President Bush asked the Taliban to turn
over Osama bin Laden and the al Qaeda
Network and mullah omar refused which
led directly to the use of force in
Afghanistan secondly she criticized the
AUMF she obviously has not read the AUMF
it gave the president the power to
target terrorists specifically it does
not say a word
about in gating of invading Afghanistan
and it reserves the powers of Congress
under the War Powers Act it was not an
unlimited AUMF now Congress may have
later abdicated its responsibility but
the AUM AUM F itself was actually
limited and not only that you're gonna
say in the aftermath of the most
devastating terror attack in the history
of the United States that you would not
have authorized the President to take
action against terrorists how does she
think that the president actually
targeted terror finance networks it was
under the AUMF the AUMF was the legal
authority for that so again this is just
her being aggressively stupid her saying
aggressively incorrect things but that's
no shock because this is what she does
and she's not just aggressively
incorrect and aggressively wrong about
Afghanistan obviously she's also
aggressively defending anti-semitism as
I mentioned so she is now engaging in
obvious what about ISM so what about ISM
is this this term that has come about in
the aftermath of President Trump really
which suggests that when someone says
something bad about Trump people say
yeah well what about Hillary and it's
dumb it's dumb because when Trump does
something bad it's bad and when Hillary
does something bad it's bad now what you
can do is say that that's not what about
ISM so if for example you say it's bad
when Trump does it and also it was bad
when Hillary Clinton did it that's not
what about ISM that is pointing out
consistent standards but a OC engages in
full-on what about ISM with regard to
anti-semitism essentially suggesting
that we should let ill Hanauma off the
hook for her anti-semitism because in
her view other bigotry has not been
excoriated harshly enough and even in
the process of making this defense she's
aggressively ignorant so she tweets out
one of the things that is hurtful about
the extent to which reprimand is sought
of ill Han is that no one seeks this
level of reprimand when members make
statements about latinx
and other communities during the
shutdown a GOP member yelled go back to
Puerto Rico on the floor she's not even
right about this during the shutdown
Republicans yelled at Democrats go back
to Puerto Rico not because the Democrats
were Puerto Rican but because Democrats
were vacationing in Puerto Rico during
the government shutdown so she's just
wrong about this and I'm old enough to
remember when the house including
Republicans voted to censure Steve King
on the floor of the house and they
stripped him of his
assignments and yet here she is saying
that Ilhan Omar should undergo nothing
that is classic what about ISM she says
it's not my position to tell people how
to feel or that their hurt is invalid
which is of course exactly what she is
doing but incidents like these do beg
the question where are the resolutions
against homophobic statements for anti
blackness for xenophobia from members
saying he'll send Obama home to Kenya I
assume she's talking about mark Meadows
now who said in a rally back in 2012
something about this which nobody even
remembered or knew anything about until
now basically but Steve King is the best
available comp and she just ignores the
fact that Steve King was just stripped
of all of his committee assignments she
says in this administration and all
others we should actively check
anti-semitism anti-blackness homophobia
racism and all other forms of bigotry
and the most productive end goal and we
see it is to educate and heal it's the
difference between calling in and
calling out this is where we get into
her her minority Studies classes at
Boston University where she starts
lecturing people like a psychologist
like she knows anything about what she's
talking about calling out is one of the
measures of last resort not first or
second resort we do it when repeated
attempts to call in are disrespected or
ignored and I believe that Ilhan in her
statement a few weeks ago has
demonstrated a willingness to work and
listen with impacted communities which
is absolute sure horse nonsense
she has legitimately dropped three
anti-semitic slurs in the course of six
weeks and here as AOC saying well you
know we just need to educate ill and
that's really what it's about lady you
need some education you're the one who's
hanging out with Jeremy Corbyn and
defending open anti-semitism even bought
younger sargon who's the editor of the
far-left newspaper the forward she says
how exactly is it hurtful when the right
thing is done for Jews just because it
wasn't done elsewhere shouldn't that
mean we work harder to condemn other
forms of hurtful speech not that we were
framed when it's Jews it's not a
zero-sum game it's so disappointing to
see a cast as such and then a else he
says it's not zero-sum and we have a
serious responsibility to listen to
communities when they feel pain where I
struggle is how we deal with that pain
the how after the what I also if you're
brooding resentment because people of
color are always promised that people
will work harder without commitment what
in the world is she talking about so she
immediately swivels back into I'm going
to ignore the anti-semitism because
maybe will upset people of color what is
she even talking about well get some
more of a Oh cease aggressive aggressive
ignorance and and the painful excuses
being made for her and for L hen Omar
and for a shooter to leave in just one
second first let's talk about something
we can all agree on saving money
opinions aren't like smartphones
everybody has them but we can all agree
that getting the best deal is important
when shopping online you probably heard
me talk about honey it's an amazing free
browser extension that automatically
helps me save money on all my favorite
sites I wouldn't be doing this my job if
I didn't tell you about how honey makes
even Amazon better I love amazon.com I
buy an enormous number of products from
Amazon and I save money nearly every
time because I am using honey with
millions of sellers on Amazon selling
the same products how do you know you're
really getting the best price you don't
unless you're using honey as you shop on
Amazon honey's best price finder
automatically compares the prices of
millions of sellers that carry the item
you want honey even factors in shipping
sales tax and Amazon Prime status to
make sure you're getting the lowest
total price it shows you the best deal
every time even if Amazon doesn't it's
like having your very own smart shopping
assistant I've bought on honey recently
about some weights for my wife she
started working out and honey saved us a
bunch of money on that it saves us a
bunch of money pretty much every week
more than 10 million people are using
honey to save money right now so next
time you're shopping on Amazon treat
yourself to the free upgrade that
guarantees you always get the absolute
best price add honey for free at join
honey calm / Ben that is join honey calm
/ Ben honey the smart shopping assistant
that helps you save time and money go
check them out right now okay so a OCS
aggressive ignorant doesn't stop there
believe it or not so she also is
aggressively ignorant when it comes to
her own policies so AOC for example
suggests that she can that she's upset
when she gets 10 plastic bags at the
stores she's trying to make excuses for
the fact that she is a consumerist the
way the most Americans are she says that
she gets upset at how many plastic bags
she has hands it at the store be upset
that I get 10 plastic bags at the
grocery store and then have to toss out
my plastic bags because the recycling
program in the area is tough and that's
okay we all of these are not reasons to
stop fighting all of these are reasons
to keep fighting and these are all
reasons and pieces of evidence to say
hey we need to make it easier to recycle
okay well again you know it's one
solution to people
ten plastic bags at the grocery not
taking them
I know unbelievable right personal
choice I love that according to folks on
the left personal choice at least on the
radical left personal choice is not
something you engage in the only time
you should make a choice is when
government forces you to do it so AOC
will continue taking the 10 plastic bags
and then throwing them away in the
garbage to be flushed away into the
ocean and killed the dolphins or
something until the government tells her
not to do it but she's gonna stump for
the government to tell her not to do it
until then she just won't do any of it
yeah I legitimately
I live in LA in LA they don't give you
bags unless you ask for the bags and
sometimes they make you pay for the bags
and very often I will say no to the bags
I believe New York has the same rules so
I'm not sure what she's whining about
but nonetheless she is indeed whining
about all of that
also AOC says that we should be talking
about investigating president Trump so
add to the - the ignorance and hypocrisy
bandwagon for aoc she says that the real
issue in American politics right now
is that we are not aggressive enough
about talking about president Trump's
money so here she is going off on
president Trump and his lack of
transparency I think in oversight we
should be talking about taxes taxes
taxes and his bank account his bank
account his bank account his financial
statement statement statement because
that's where I think actually some of
the most troubling practices are with
direct relevance to the American people
under the scope of oversight yeah all of
that is fine and dandy unless it turns
out that your chief of staff was
funneling a million dollars in slush
funds from the campaign to LLC's run by
him with no actual transparency as to
where the money went
that's according to Alana Goodman over
at the Washington Examiner two political
action committees founded by aoc top
aide funneled over 1 million dollars in
political donations into two of his own
private companies according to a
complaint filed with the FEC on Monday
the cash transfers from the PACs
overseen by psychotic labardi the
freshman socialist Democrats chief of
staff run counter to her pledges to
increase transparency and reduce the
influence of dark money in politics
Chakrabarti x' companies appear to have
been set up for the sole purpose of
obscuring how the political donations
were used the arrangement skirted
reporting requirements and may have
violated the $5,000 limit on
contributions from federal PACs to
candidates according to the complaint
filed by the National legal and Policy
Center a government watchdog group
campaign finance attorneys described the
arrangement as really weird and an
indication there is something amiss they
said there was no way of telling where
the political donations win meaning they
could have been pocketed or used by the
company to pay for off the books
campaign operations in other words what
happened is that a o'seas campaign
basically funneled or a super PAC
associated with with AOC funneled a
million dollars a million dollars to to
shell companies controlled by her chief
of staff and then no one knows where the
money went
and FEC lawyers are looking into this
now this may be a violation of law adavi
no Dee's a senior director for the
campaign Legal Center and a former FEC
lawyer he said the arrangement was
highly unusual and seemed intended to
obscure the destination of the funds he
said none of this makes any sense I
can't even begin to disentangle that
they're either confused or they're
trying to conceal something he says it
does seem like there's something amiss I
can only think of really two likely
possibilities for this sort of pattern
of disbursements one is a scam pack
possibility they're really just paying
themselves and they're concealing it by
using the LLC the other is that there's
actually another recipient that the
money is going to the LLC and then being
dispersed in some other way that they
want to conceal so none of this is very
good for AOC but here's the thing none
of it matters for AOC because in the end
the Democratic Party is going to
continue to defend it's fresh faces why
do they continue to defend the fresh
faces because the higher-ups in politics
understand that at this point in time it
is better to have a bunch of
aggressively ignorant but attractive
faces at the head of your party than it
is to have somebody who knows what the
hell they're talking about
Nancy Pelosi is happy to have a IOC out
there pushing the envelope broadening
the Overton Window raising the issues
even if it means that she's gonna say
dumb things every once in a while
because the Democrats are fully aware
that they can walk this stuff back this
is one of the benefits to having a media
that is willing to cover for any amount
of insanity on your side of the
political aisle the media bias that
allows Democrats to get away with
legitimately everything is pretty
amazing it's really truly amazing so for
example the Democrats right now have
been engaging in a cover-up of open
anti-semitism and Politico is covering
for them Politico has an article today
says House Dems
take floor action to confront Omar's
latest Israel comments and their big
question here is not whether Ilhan Omar
should be personally called out of
course because we can't personally call
out el ha Omar the same way that Steve
King was personally censured on the
floor of the house No Ilhan Omar
shouldn't be personally called out the
real issue here according to the
according to Politico as the GOP leaders
have begun to pounce
it's the GOP leaders pouncing and it's
not just political the New York Times
headlined about all of this
Johan Omar's criticism raises the
question is AIPAC too powerful what in
the living hell is that headline so her
anti-semitism did not raise the question
is her anti-semitism correct when Steve
King said what he said about white
nationalism the New York Times did not
ask the question Steve King's comments
raised the question is white nationalism
stigmatized like what in the hell are
they talking about the answer is the New
York Times is fine with sliding over
into anti-semitism because they are so
radically anti-israel they don't even
see the line and here's the truth you
can criticize Israel of course you can
criticize apec I've criticized AIPAC I
thought APEC did a garbage job when it
came to stumping against the Iran deal
even criticized the State of Israel I've
criticized a bunch of administration's
including B B's but there is a
distinction between that and claiming
that general support for Israel is
pushed by Jewish money and Jewish dual
loyalty which is what Ilhan Omar
actually said until hen Tamar actually
it must be beautiful to have the media
on your sides of this extent it must
make life so incredibly easy now what it
does lead to when the media are
constantly parroting talking points is
these awkward moments when reality
breaks through and we get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
how you protect your online activity
admit it you think cyber crime is
something that happens to other people
you may think that no one wants your
data or that hackers can't grab your
passwords or credit card details but you
would be wrong
stealing data from unsuspecting people
on public Wi-Fi is one of the simplest
and cheapest ways for hackers to make
money when you leave your internet
connection unencrypted you might as well
be writing your passwords and credit
card numbers on a huge billboard for the
rest of the world to see that's why I
decided to take action to protect myself
from cyber criminals I use expressvpn
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
Express
has easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly
in the background of your computer phone
and tablet turning on expressvpn
protection that only takes one click
using expressvpn I can safely surf on
public Wi-Fi without being snooped on or
having my personal data stolen for less
than seven bucks a month you can get the
same expressvpn protection that I have
expressvpn is rated the number one VPN
service by TechRadar it comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee protect your
online activity today find out how you
can get three months for free at
expressvpn comm slash Ben that's expr
ESS VPN comm slash been for three months
free with a one-year package visit
expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn more
well as I say the media is willingness
to cover for virtually any left-wing
narrative benefits the left not only in
allowing them to defend against the
insane things that so many folks on the
radical left say but it also pushes a
narrative the benefits the left a
narrative of impending doom and crisis a
narrative that America is a terrible
place that requires deep-seated change
in the nature of the American bargain in
order for justice to be done and every
so often this media experience runs up
against reality
first it convinces a lot of people you
want to know one of the reasons why
politics feels so critical today you
people are so polarized it's because our
amygdalas light up every time there's a
headline because the media make a lot of
money off crisis thinking off the idea
that this is the end of the world that
being alive is in essence a dangerous
bargain and none of that is true so the
impact of media coverage on stuff like
this is a constant feeling of crisis
which of course would require constant
government intervention bigger
government intervention more cover for
people like aoc who after all are just
trying to do the right thing in the end
the defense that the media make of
people like Johanna Maher and AOC and
Rasheeda Talib and Jeremy Corbyn the
defense that they are constantly making
of these folks is heavily reliant on the
fact that they think that if you have to
break a few eggs to make an omelet you
break a few eggs to make an omelet
because the world is in peril and this
leads millions of people into a certain
crisis mentality about the state of the
world that simply is not accurate so
indicator of that crisis mentality
there's amazing video from the BBC of
this crazy group of women who are now
suggesting that they are not going to
have children because of the danger
global warming and listen to the
rhetoric these women are spouting and
the BBC humoring it patting them on the
head basically suggesting that maybe
they're right AOC has said the same
thing right AOC said last week maybe
people shouldn't have kids because of
climate change now this has become a
thing in Britain women pledging not to
have children because of climate change
our planet is in a kind of collapse the
natural world is collapsing around us
and that's actually happening right now
and I'm so disappointed by the response
by authorities to this crisis and so
freaked out by it everything I've read
that I've basically last year I came to
the decision that I couldn't bring a
child into that if we're in this
situation now you know even since my
parents had me we've destroyed 60% of of
life on this planet what would that be
like when my child's my it will that be
10% laughs okay this is this is just
sure craziness okay so she's suggesting
humanity's wiped out 60% of animal
population since 1970 that is according
to a particular environmental report it
is very questionable as to whether this
is actually true
Edie young over at the Atlantic says
that that that finding has been widely
mischaracterized the team behind Living
Planet Index relied on previous studies
in which researchers estimated the size
of different animal populations whether
through direct counts camera traps
satellites or proxies like the presence
of nests or tracks the team's collated
such estimates for 16700 populations of
mammals birds reptiles amphibians and
fish across 4,000 species that covers
just 6.4 percent of the sixty-three
thousand or so species of vertebrates
that is backbone animals that are
thought to exist and then they
calculated that the size of vertebrate
populations has declined by 60 percent
on average which does not mean that
humans have called 60% of animals hey
the report itself says that's not true
but the media covered it as though 60%
of animals were dying that is simply not
the case the media have an interest in
promoting the idea that the world is in
grave danger
so that we hand more power over to
ignorant people who pledged to fix
everything because the media agrees with
their general agenda now here's the
reality about the world we live in it's
a
unbelievable place it's a truly
incredible place here's an article from
the New York Times you want to know
about the ingenuity of humankind
you know you want to know about the
incredible innovativeness and
adaptiveness of human beings this is an
unbelievable story there's from the New
York Times today today and this will get
a lot like less coverage than the idea
that we are on the verge of a meltdown
in terms of human life and that we must
give all control of government did to
government because of great inequality
and burgeoning civil war analyst it's
just not true a poor v''e mandevilla
reporting HIV reported cured in a second
patient scientists have long tried to
duplicate the procedure that led to the
first long-term remission 12 years ago
with the so-called London patient they
seemed to have succeeded for the second
time since the global epidemic began a
patient appears to have been cured of
infection with HIV the virus that causes
AIDS the news comes nearly 12 years to
the day after the first patient known to
be cured a feat that researchers have
long tried and failed to duplicate the
surprise success now confirms that a
cure for HIV infection is possible if
difficult researchers said publicly the
scientists are describing the cases
alone from remission in interviews most
experts are calling it a cure with the
caveat that it is hard to know how to
define the word when there are only two
known instances we live in a time when
we are developing toward cures for
diseases that have wiped thousands of
people and in Africa tens of thousands
of people off planet earth we live in a
time when we have wiped out some of the
gravest diseases that have ever
threatened mankind we live in a time
with more prosperity and more freedom
than any time in human history and we
are being told by the media at every
turn that everything is a crisis and if
everything is a crisis then we look for
an easy solution and the easy solution
comes in the form of a bumper sticker
the truth is there are very few easy
solutions the only easy solution is to
let people live to leave people alone to
let innovativeness sprout to treat other
people with a generalized level of
tolerance even if you disagree with them
that's the actual solution but when the
media are constantly promoting the idea
of doom and gloom it's the end of the
world we're all gonna die the natural
instinct is to turn to people who share
radical solutions and that aggressive
ignorance again is not only promoted by
media anybody who cuts against the
aggressive ignorance anybody who cuts
against that narrative is deemed not
efficiently woke so for example best
story of the day along these lines
Google has done a study they studied
their own pay and here's what the study
found they found that men were being
systematically underpaid as compared
with women why does that matter
because then Google treads walk back the
results of its own studies so as to
agree with the generalized narrative
that America is sexist including Google
it's unbelievable woken Asst this is
this belief that America is naturally
bad that the West is naturally filled
with inequality and poverty and cruelty
and malice and that the earth is dying
because of the West this belief has been
so inculcated into the media and by the
media that we are willing to by sheer
nonsense from politicians who mirror
that belief even as they say crazy
things on every other score and we're
and we're willing to overlook all of the
worst things they say because after all
they are morally right as aoc has said
before factually wrong doesn't matter
only morally right matters in a second
I'm gonna tell you more about this
Google study which again we have known
this stuff for years there is nothing
new here women are treated unbelievably
well in the United States women actually
have the upper hand when it comes to
college degrees women have an upper hand
when it comes to many life choices
seriously in the United States hey let's
not pretend that women are a victim
class in the United States they simply
are not they seem that sounds to say
there aren't individual victimized women
of course there are but that is not the
same as saying that females represent a
majority of the voting population and a
majority of College degreed people are a
victim class in the United States that's
it's a ridiculous contention but we
can't say that if we say that we're
undercutting the narrative of
cataclysmic horror that apparently is is
over running the American bargain we'll
talk about that in just a second we'll
talk about how the media have convinced
themselves that reporting fiction is
more important than reporting fact
simply to maintain the woke bargain in
just a second first let's talk about how
you can get out of that credit card debt
for decades credit cards have been
telling us to buy it now pay for it
later with interest despite your best
intentions that interest can get out of
control pretty quickly with Lending Club
you can consolidate your debt or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans that means no
trips to a bank no high interest card
cards just go to Lending Club com tell
them about yourself and how much you
want to borrow pick the terms that are
right for you
if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
accounts in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash Bend
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
40 grand that is Lending Club comm slash
been Lending Club comm slash ban all
loans made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender you're responsible make
sure that you handle your credit card
debt make sure that you can consolidate
all of that and get out of the kind of
debt that could you for life go
check them out at Lending Club com /
Bend check that rate in minutes borrow
up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club com / Ben Lending
Club calm / man okay in just a second
I'm gonna get to some more of the media
just absolutely pushing a particular
line that results in the victory of the
most ignorant among us and the people
who are lying about the state of West
the state of the world at this point in
time we'll get to that in just second
first you're gonna have to go subscribe
at daily wire $9.99 a month that makes
sure that you can get a subscription and
two hours of the show later later on
today for example we are having on the
incredible Adam Corolla the Godfather of
all podcasting we're having Adam on a
little bit later so check that out for
$9.99 a month you too can be part of the
daily wire for $99 ear you get all of
that and more you also get this the
daily wire leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr the finest and all beverage
vessels curing disease the world over I
can't actually make that claim maybe
curing disease the world over go check
that out right now also we have Sundays
specials coming up that are just going
to be awesome we have a couple of
Sundays specials that are coming up I
know who the guests are but you don't
but you will if you subscribe and you
get the Sunday specials a day early you
me part of our mailbag I answer
questions from our subscribers during
breaks on the radio every afternoon so
you can be part of that as well we have
so many goodies for you go check us out
over there also subscribed over at
YouTube or iTunes leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in America
so as I say the victory of people like
aoc o Hanuman Rasheeda Talib and to a
certain extent Donald Trump relies on
the media pushing this notion of crisis
that we are constantly in and that
notion of crisis is simply not true and
when reality butts up against that that
narrative of crisis the media don't know
what to do neither do our our big tech
overlords who want to push that
narrative so Google has been pushing the
narrative that women are victimized in
American society then it turns out they
conducted a study to determine whether
the company was under paying women and
members of minority groups instead
Google found to the surprise of just
about everyone that men were paid less
money than women for doing similar work
the study is done every year but the
latest findings arrived as Google and
other companies in Silicon Valley face
increasing pressure to deal with gender
issues in the workplace from sexual
harassment to wage discrimination where
is that pressure coming from to a large
extent that pressure is coming from
outside woke groups that are interested
in promulgating a narrative that
counters the fact women are treated
better in Western civilization and yes
in places like Silicon Valley then
pretty much anywhere else on earth
that again does not mean that there are
not evil men who do evil things it does
not mean that there are individual women
who are not deeply mistreated and preyed
upon by men it does mean that if we are
going to say that generally women are
victimized in American society that is a
load of crap it is a load of nonsense
gender inequality is a radioactive topic
at Google says the New York Times yeah
you know why because of the New York
Times will rip Google if Google even
suggests that gender inequality is not a
massive problem at Google critics say
the result of the pay study could give a
false impression yeah who are those
critics presumably the experts at the
New York Times company officials
acknowledged it did not address whether
women were hired at a lower pay grade
than men with similar qualifications
okay well then how about some proof how
about some proof as opposed to simply
the suggestion but again a result that
finds that women are not discriminated
against is very upsetting to people on
the walk scold left here is the truth
here's the truth as early as 2010
there's a study reported in Time
magazine and it found that in 147 out of
the 150 biggest cities in the United
States the median full-time salaries of
young women were 8% higher than those of
guys in the
peer group in 147 out of 150 of the
biggest cities in the United States and
that figure by the way has not budged
hey the gap is huge in places like New
York City LA and San Diego 17% 12% 15%
as of 2010 that applies to unmarried
childless women under 30 who live in
cities right because women who have
children end up having other obligations
women who get married tend to change
their priorities that is not the fault
of employers but to point out these
facts is to under is to undercut the
consensus woke view of the world and
that cannot be allowed by the media I'll
give you a great example of this so
Robin Roberts of Good Morning America
did just a ridiculous interview you'll
recall with Jesse Smollett justice
Millette of course was the star of
Empire who now has been charged with a
racial hoax he claims that he went out
at 2:00 a.m. in Chicago and was accosted
by two mega hadded Trump fans who then
who then garrotted him with a noose
poured bleach on him while shouting this
is Magga country again at 2:00 a.m. in
the middle of a polar vortex in the city
of Chicago it was a ridiculous story on
its face everybody took it seriously
including Robin Roberts who did a full
interview with Jesse Smollett or she
basically allowed Smollett to claim that
half the country at least was racist
sexist bigoted homophobic and then Robin
Roberts was asked about this so Robin
Roberts did an interview and this just
shows you where the media's heads are at
for the media the woke narrative must
trump everything else it must trump
everything else and if the woke a
narrative does trump everything else
that means it Trump's ignorance it means
it's from stupidity it means it Trump's
the fact that people don't know what
they're talking about very often because
as long as the narrative is preserved
nothing else matters and the nerve right
now when it comes to Congress is that
the fresh faces of the Democratic Party
have something new and exciting to say
that they are the leaders who are going
to change the future that America is a
deep dark terrible place that the West
is a deep dark terrible racist bigoted
place and that we need brash newcomers
even if they're a little bit on the
jew-hating side we need those brash
newcomers to come forth and lead us to a
better future
so here's Robin Roberts on Jesse smut
you'll notice that what she says it's
truly amazing she says it was a no-win
situation doing in the interview
she so what she says is quote I'll be
completely honest I was like I don't
know if I want to do the interview or
not I said I don't want to sit down with
him if he's going to lawyer up and then
I was told he wants to speak with you
because he was outraged by people making
assumptions about whether it had
happened or not and then she finally
agreed to do the interview she said
after being told she'd be she'd be able
to ask Smollett about all the red flags
that were surrounding his story and
perhaps shed some light with new
information she said she was hoping to
remain neutral but as a gay black woman
interviewing a gay black man she felt
like she was put in a tight spot here's
the key line he's saying there's a hate
crime so if I'm too hard then my LGBT
community is going to say you don't
believe a brother if I'm too late on him
it's like oh because you are in the
community you're giving him a pass it
was in no-win situation for me how is
that a no-win situation for Robin
Roberts she's a journalist it is her job
to ask the questions but she is
admitting openly that if she was too
hard on justice Millette
she was afraid of the blowback she was
going to get from her own community for
not being woken up the media are
invested in these narratives these
narratives of social inequality and
tremendous American injustice and
tremendous American bigotry so invested
that they are over there willing to
overlook blatantly false stories they're
willing to overlook the anti-semitism of
some of the members of their own caucus
because in the end the only thing that
matters is the preservation of the
narrative that's all that matters that's
all that matters
it's vile and it's why the most
aggressively ignorant and bigoted among
us are probably going to have an upper
hand in politics for some time to come
he's speaking of which coming up and
talk in a second about that sort of
aggressive ignorant so Cynthia Nixon
I'll give you another example this
Cynthia Nixon is an actress okay she ran
for governor of New York against Andrew
Cuomo and she got shellacked now when
you get beat by Andrew Cuomo like a rug
and get beat like a rug by Andrew Cuomo
that means you're a bad politician it
means people don't like what you have to
say I mean Andrew Cuomo has about his
charisma as a stump a tree stump and
Cynthia Nixon she lost to him but now
she pressured Joe Biden so here is the
woke narrative suggests that people on
the other side of the aisle are
inherently bad they're inherently bad
for disagreeing about mainstream
political issues it's not bad to be an
anti-semite if you're on the right side
of the woke but if you're on the wrong
side of the woke
then it is very bad to take political
positions like say traditional marriage
is a good thing and the traditional
marriage is superior on a social level
to same-sex marriage to take such a
position which was officially the
position of the Democratic Party until
what six years ago to take that position
makes you a vile bad human being so
Cynthia narrative has Cynthia Nixon went
after Joe Biden why cuz Joe Biden said
that Mike Pence was a decent human and
then she was like no and Mike Pence is
not a decent human because he disagrees
with me on LGBT issues and Joe Biden
caving to the woke scolds immediately
surrendered and said you're right you
know what I changed my mind I changed my
mind it turns out that Mike Pence is no
longer a decent human being
because he disagrees with me right so
Cynthia Nixon do Plast Mike Pence
so the Duplass is a verb meaning to
cowardly stab somebody in the back who
you have no relationship to it was
coined after Mark Duplass an actor
director did the same thing to me he
said I was a decent guy online people
attacked him he took down his tweet and
then suggested that I was a racist
sexist bigoted homophobe he had run
afoul of the woke skulls so Cynthia
Nixon is then given space in the
Washington Post this is our media the
Washington Post to sit to to sort of
blow up her claims who fully claim that
Mike Pence is actually a bigot and in
the process of her column in the
Washington Post
she makes a variety of false claims
about Mike Pence personally this op-ed
in the Washington Post
she says that pence was insidious and
just lies about pence his record she
says he signed a religious freedom bill
that would have allowed LGBTQ
discrimination that is false he actually
called for changes to the bill that
quote make it clear discrimination won't
be allowed that Mike Pence quote refused
to lift a ban on needle exchange
programs until a preventable HIV
outbreak reached epidemic levels that is
again false he issued an executive order
in March 2015
allowing distribution of needles while
also acknowledging that there are
serious public health concerns about
needle exchanges
she said he suggested support for
so-called conversion therapy again that
is a lie there's no mention of
conversion therapy on his website the
one that she cites she says that he
published an article urging businesses
not to hire gay people that's utterly
false outright she just made all of
these false claims in the pages of The
Washington Post
totally fine you can lie about the vice
to the United States because it supports
the narrative and that narrative will
continue to be supported because it is
unfalsifiable this is the beautiful
thing about the wolf narrative if you
say hey wait a second you don't have you
don't have any evidence that Mike Pence
is a bigot you don't have evidence that
America is a terribly bigoted homophobic
racist sexist place you don't have any
evidence that America is a terrible
place or that it requires the solutions
of full-on socialists then the left will
say well that's because you your your
eyes have not been opened because you
don't see the truth but once you see the
truth you can't unsee the truth and this
is how you end up with the ridiculous
spectacle the ridiculous insane
spectacle of brie Larson an actress who
does not know things speaking at the
Women in Film Festival about her new
movie Captain Marvel now the the execs
over at Disney have just got to be
beside themselves because it turns out
that a lot of the people who like to go
watch comic book movies are young men
and Captain Marvel was already a little
bit outside the box in the sense that it
is a female superhero now young men will
go see a female superhero they will
wonder woman made a boatload of money at
the office at the box office but brie
Larson suggests that America is a sexist
bigoted terrible homophobic place and
then she goes even further she says that
she doesn't care if white people go to
see her movies because she's not gonna
take criticism from white people she is
a white woman here she is going off
again
backing the walk narrative and what this
is really meant to do seriously what
this is meant to do is provide cover
because for people who are at least half
clever if they understand that the media
is willing to provide cover for anyone
who echoes the woken air ative then the
best thing to do is to echo the walk
near enough right that way if your movie
is a bomb and it sucks then they can
just blame all of those terrible no good
very bad boys it's all those it's all
those boys who wouldn't go see the movie
because they were sexist it's not that
your movie was garbage it's that these
evil terrible boys but it was you
remember we did this with the with with
Lady Ghostbusters lady Ghostbusters is
not a good movie I'm not even a fan of
the original Ghostbusters lady
Ghostbusters is not a good movie but
because it was made with women and
because it didn't do well at the box
office it turned into it's it's non
success was not a referendum on the
filmmakers it was a referendum on
America
deep sexism well brie Larson is playing
right into that here is brie Larson
actively alienating her chief audience
so that I guess later she can claim that
it's not her fault when the movie if and
when the movie bombs our industry has
gone through a major growth we are
expanding to make films that better
reflect the people that buy movie
tickets but they are not allowed enough
chances to read public discourse on
these films by the people that these
films were made for I do not need a
40-year old white dude to tell me what
didn't work for him about a wrinkle in
time it wasn't made for him I want to
know what that film meant to women of
color too biracial women to teen women
of color duties that are biracial oh
really who does she think buys tickets
in this country does she think that the
entire that that when Disney sunk a
hundred million dollars into a wrinkle
in time that they were looking to
actively alienate 40 year old men who by
the way who do you think is bringing
their daughters to these movies it's a
bunch of 40 year old guys and when I'm
40 my daughter is going to be 10 okay
I'm gonna be the one bringing her to
movies with people like brie Larson does
she actually think that alienating
people like me is going to be big box
office of course not she knows that
she's not completely dumb but she also
knows that the media are now going to
lay the groundwork for the failure of
her film so if her film falls apart if
it's just a mediocrity it's going to
turn into America's a deeply terrible
place
now what's hilariously unfalsifiable
about this is that if Black Panther does
unbelievable business that is not proof
that America is not racist America is
still racist even if Black Panther does
a bajillion at the box office and gets
nominated for Best Picture despite being
in my opinion the fourth best comic book
movie of the last year America still
racist even a Black Panther does well
but if Captain Marvel fails it'll be
because of American sexism therefore we
need more women empowerment therefore
aoc that's how this math works it's
ridiculous it's insipid America is a
pretty wonderful place and ignorance is
no it should not be excused simply
because the ignorance tends to support
the woken air ative okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like so I had
heard a lot about this Marie Kondo thing
and I actually went out and got her book
the life change
magic of tidying up and I have been
going through it and I will admit I like
this thing I do now I know it's a little
it's a little touchy-feely there's a lot
of stuff in there about thanking objects
before you throw them out but contrary
to popular opinion I actually do have
feelings particularly about the stuff in
my house and she is not wrong that
thanking objects before throwing them
away for example it's not about the
object obviously taking account of your
feelings but it is about you
recognizing the your memories are going
to remain even if you throw away a
particular item of clothing that you
haven't worn for 30 years there's a lot
of good advice in this book really and I
listen I have young kids that means my
house is constantly a mess like all the
time because they take out their toys I
tell them put them away they argue with
me they put away 3/4 of the toys and
then the other quarter of the toys are
left until I have time to actually put
them away but she is correct that going
through one large spate of cleaning your
house is significantly better than
constantly cleaning I just went through
my wardrobe a couple of days ago and I
gave away like half the stuff in there
to Goodwill my my my closet is cleaner I
feel better about it so give it a dry
seriously I know really off-brand right
but go check it out the way of changing
magic of tidying up by Marie Kondo kind
of a fun book okay other things that I
like so I have to acknowledge when we're
talking about the woke media and the
world narrative there are certain
questions that the woke media can ask
that nobody else is allowed to ask
because these questions are actually
racist so Bernie Sanders was asked by
Charlemagne the God on one of these
podcasts about Charlene the goddess what
a rapper yes okay thank you so Bernie
Sanders the leading Democratic
presidential candidate in a near
octogenarian Socialist who has never
done a productive thing in his life he
was asked about whether America needs
another white president now let's just
stop there for a second you know wildly
and insanely inappropriate that is why
wouldn't America need another white
president can you imagine anybody saying
listen we had Barack Obama do you suck
do we really need another black
president that'd be ridiculous it
depends on who the black person is I
said this one Obama was elected I didn't
want Obama to be President because I
wanted a better qualified black person
because I wanted a better qualified
person I wanted someone who agreed with
my principles I didn't care about his
race I'm more than fine with having a
black president I would
like that black president to agree with
all of my principles on politics well
folks on the Left though for them that's
not enough so they're asking Bernie
Sanders whether he is too white to be
President
Bernie Sanders his answer is pretty much
spot-on here
so Bernie 44 out of 45 presidents in
this country have been white men do you
think we need another one well you need
this one look we are living in an
unprecedented time we have the most
dangerous president in the modern
history this country somebody who is a
pathological liar a fraud a racist the
sexist the homophobe a risotto con man a
cheat
now you just get warmed up you know this
is a bad news guy the most important
thing that has got to happen is that
this dangerous president is defeated
okay so his rip on Trump is obviously
inane and it's in sort of typical Road
he just has the list in his head he
flips through the rolodex that's not the
good part of the answer the part of the
answer that is good is he says listen
you should just look at me as a
candidate they stopped looking at my
race now this is pissed off the woke
left the woke left is upset about this
because in their view
Bernie Sanders is too post-racial you
need someone who's going to back the
idea that we need a black president to
fix a country that is historically
racist even though we just had a black
president for eight years and the
country actually got more racially
polarized as a result of his deliberate
stoking of racial flames and good for
Bernie Sanders for a fusing to back down
on this issue honestly I would rather
have Bernie Sanders view on race then
then Kamala Harris's views on race and I
think that Bernie Sanders has views on
class are actually less dangerous to the
country than Kamala Harris has views on
race because America is not going to be
divided by class we won't there's too
much income mobility in the United
States the vast majority of people who
earn inside the 1% this year will not
earn inside the 1% in ten years and have
not earned inside the 1% ten years
before class distinction that's in the
United States are largely artificial
race the attempt to try belies people by
race is much more dangerous to American
politics that's what I like about
burning inside the Democratic Party so
alright time for a couple of things that
I hate
well there comes a point with the woke
when you're so woke that your brains
fall out one of these incidents comes
courtesy of the Daily Mirror tonight so
the Daily Mirror is a newspaper in
London and here is the title of their
piece married lesbian couple are now
husband and wife after one became a man
and then it says tie and Ania Kennedy
from Florida say they don't care about
genders as they are madly in love I'm
gonna go with that's not what happened
that a married lesbian couple are now
husband and wife after one became a man
I'm fairly certain that the husband is
still a woman but it's going to make
things real awkward for the left if they
continue along these lines because
they're going to have to decide whether
sex is innate or whether sexual
orientation is is innate they can't have
it both ways if sex is not innate and
you can simply change your sex well then
sexual orientation is also malleable and
you can actually just change your sexual
orientation I mean this is the first
line of the article childhood
sweethearts tie and Ania Kennedy were
both females when they started dating
five years ago but they now identify as
husband and wife in a straight
relationship after table and to undergo
the transitioning process to become a
man so it was funny folks on the Left
were trying to get out of this rather
illogical conundrum by suggesting that
they're both bisexual but they don't
consider themselves bisexual the girl
apparently though the one who actually
stayed a woman according to the wefts
logic became straight she said it not me
so you want to argue with her about her
sexual orientation have at it man but
apparently her sexual orientation was
malleable which is not allowed but sex
was also malleable which is allowed or
it could be that male and female are
innate categories and that sexual
orientation is not nearly as malleable
because a lot of this stuff is innate
maybe all of that is true but again the
left is so confused they don't even know
how to characterize this stuff anymore
so well done folks on the left and this
is always been puzzling you know the
kind of grouping together of LGBTQ has
always been kind of weird because the
truth is that tea tends to overrule LGB
once you obliterate the distinction
between the sexes then what's the need
for categories like LGB anymore
sexuality simply becomes fluid you don't
need lesbianism the idea that you prefer
women to men why would that exactly be a
category if women can be men and men can
be women obviously there's some rather
deep illogic here but the left doesn't
need logic all they need is a narrative
all right
well we'll be back here a little bit
later today Adam Carolla will be
stopping by we'll have much more to talk
about so this is why you should
subscribe you can get two hours of our
show later today commercial-free go
check us out then if not we'll see you
back here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19